all right we've got a few one of the
solutions here to discuss briefly and
then we'll get on to our content for
today let's start at the top now you can
see I'd love you to have a look we've
got two solutions here there's a left
hand side right hand side I want you to
look carefully and just quietly raise
your hand if you did it this left hand
way the orange way hands up straight so
four five six six hence thank you hands
down and then who did the other way the
blue way hands up
okay a similar number maybe a few more
thinking is that did anyone do it
differently to both of those ways
Christians like kind of one step
different so essentially the same thing
but slightly different so what are our
names for these by the way what was it
that I'm Leah or Kyra who did this one
Kyra okay so what did Kira do she
expanded very good so expand that left
hand side and then you know rearranged
to try do the same thing to both sides
and we ended up with this solution left
hand solution what was the name and we
gave to this what do we do we didn't
expand at all we divide it very good we
didn't divide by just anything we
divided by the what am I looking for why
did she choose the number three it looks
like to me why did she choose three the
ways right okay so nines of nines of
multiple 3s divisible by three okay
excellent and it does get rid of this
thing at the front which means I don't
have to expand yeah one lot of X minus
two is X minus two okay and a nice
confirmation we've got the same thing
down the bottom which either means we
both have it right or coincidentally we
both did it wrong enough that we ended
up on the same mistake which would be
highly unlikely let's have a look over
here there's not a huge amount of
working required for this one is there
have a look closely
you've got square root of hundred
thirty-two why is that square root sign
still there why can't I get rid of it ma
okay so this 132 it's not a square
number is it not not a nice neat square
now it's between 121 on one side and 144
on the other what's the importance of
these numbers what time 321
it's 11 squared 144 12 squared so this
number is actually going to be between
11 and 12
but mrs. Lee's asked us to leave the
answer is absurd so that's where the
square root sign is what's this thing
hanging out the front what's that about
plus or minus is a positive and a
negative solution okay last one now this
one who gave us a solution here and gave
us a solution so we had to do an extra
thing here to get to this line that we
did in question 2 what was the extra
thing yeah we added 9 to both sides and
then we got a situation just like before
are you happy with that okay all right
very good
can I just oh yeah willing to jump
question or thought do you need the plus
or minus on this is that what you're
asking
that's a great question Williams asked
you to my question - yeah do we need the
positive negative do we need the plus
minus on this just like we have it on
this does anyone have any thoughts
before I jump in who reckons that the
plus minus should be there a few hands
up David you're gonna hand up it yeah
leave your hand up um would anyone be
willing to suggest why we need it not
just that we do but why yeah but I could
go ahead
you're a great yes do you have a reason
why you agree David were you gonna say
something similar or different to that
you want to go ahead and share with the
costumes just it yes go ahead okay
you're asking about whether we have this
on the top or this on the top so you're
asking okay so I did say I would talk
about this another time well then were
you asking whether I need this sign at
all was that the question yeah okay so
this is what we'll use talking Matt and
this is really interesting actually I
was really glad that this is the
direction you're going in because I want
you to turn back to yesterday's exercise
can you just turn back to that real
quick because we kind of let you do this
question on your own but then I didn't
discuss it any further I think one of
the questions you got might look like
this
was this one of the questions do you
have that exact time just do it for
memory okay now the question said that
you can't find any solutions that you
remember that yeah now this is what
Williams talking about we can't take the
square root of a negative number at
least not yet right now this is very
important this is different to this
isn't it where's the minus sign here
it's kind of attached to that number
right so that's why if you took the
square root of that you'd be like oh oh
that that doesn't look good
you can go ahead you can try popping
into your calculator and your calculator
will not be very happy with you okay but
this is different
do you see this is different that minus
sign is not underneath the square root
it's actually on the outside and that's
totally fine can you all eat your
calculator actually can you get your
calculator out for me if you haven't
already what I'd like you to do is input
that number there put the minus sign out
the front then pop in the square root
and 132 okay now when you're in equals
when you hit equals
you get negative eleven point for a
night thank you dear
okay so you've got that negative eleven
and all the decimal places okay now
after you've hit equals you've got the
number there can I ask the next button
you press can you square that please can
you square it and then get the answer
from that square equals one one thirty
two which is kind of what we wanted from
the beginning right in other words this
number you've got this negative eleven
point what was it four nine four eight
nine that number which I've written
misses no sorry who Bharathi wrote on
this line here that negative eleven
point etc which bravas put in third form
it obeys it satisfies this original
equation which means to go back to the
original question William yes it
actually does work okay does that make
sense so we do need that okay now one
last quick thing just because um we
talked about it okay the text looks a
little bit sneaky here what did it say
in terms of this equation or what did
you say how many solutions did it have
this equation here so the textbook
actually it worded it this way right
now there's a reason it does this I did
here focus in the police thinking you
can look at that letter sorry here's a
reason it says this but I actually want
you to put your pens down I'm just going
to write a couple of equations on the
board and see if you can follow along
with me why this is important don't say
it out loud but you know what the answer
to this expression is right you could
evaluate it right what about this one
sorry I took Missy could you evaluate
that you can write but once upon a time
you couldn't once-upon-a-time is someone
it said this to you you'd say I know
what 7 take away 5 is but if you had 5
things and you tried to subtract 7 you'd
run out of things right once upon a time
when you're much younger that's what you
would have said you would have said that
has no solutions ok in a similar way you
can tell me what the answer to that is
right yeah I hope you can ok now once
upon a time once upon a time you would
have just
as easily have said well you can't do
that you can't do it
that's what once upon a time you would
have said because there are different
kinds of nama see what kind of numbers
do you need to be able to give an answer
that you need negative number and for
this you also need another kind of
number you need a a fraction or a
decimal right I guess in this case it'll
be four four sevenths I think okay so we
needed new kinds of numbers okay now I'm
gonna tell you about it just yet but
there are new other kinds of numbers
which if you want to ask mrs. Luiza know
about later you can then actually we'll
give you answers but that's for another
time